مساء الخير اهلا بكم الى نشره الرابعه من
الرياض والتي نقدم من خلالها ابرز اخبار
ملفات السعوديه والخليج وهذه ابرز عناوين
اليوم
تسريب لاحد قاده الباسيج يكشف عن ارهاق
قوات الامن الايرانيه من مكافحه
الاحتجاجات
الرياض تحتضن قمه المجلس العلمي للسفر
والسياحه اتفاقيات عالميه ب 50 مليار
دولار
الرابعه تفتح ملف التعثر المشاريع الناشئه
في السعوديه رغم التسهيلات الحكوميه
المستمره
ومن ملفاتنا في الرابعه كذلك
خلال اقل من 40 يوما على انطلاقه موسم
الرياض يجذب اكثر من خمسه ملايين زائر
صراع الدور الاول في المونديال يبدا جوله
الحسم موقعه امريكيه ايرانيه بنكهه
السياسه
حياكم الله نبدا من ايران حيث اعلنت شرطه
العاصمه طهران عن اعتقال خمسه اشخاص
وصفتهم بعناصر مثيره للشغب في حي نزال
اباد شرق العاصمه حسب مزاعم الشرطه فان
هؤلاء الاشخاص حاولوا تسجيل وثائقي حول ما
قاموا به من اشعال النار في صناديق
القمامه واغلاق الشوارع وكتابه الشعارات
ونشر ما سجلوا وارساله الى الشبكات
الافتراضيه المعاديه تشويش الراي العام
في هذا السياق نشر تلفزيون ايران
انترناشونال تسجيل صوتيه مسربا لاجتماعي
مسؤولي الاعلام الرسمي الايراني مع نائب
قائد منظمه الباسيج قاسم قريشي وذلك عقب
اختراقي وكاله انباء فارس التابعه للحرس
الثوري
مسؤولو الاعلام الرسميه اعربوا عن قلقه من
ارهاق قوات الامن على خلفيه قمع
الاحتجاجات واضراب التجار في اثنتين 22
محافظه وبحسب التقارير وصل معدل اغلاق
الاسواق في الخامسه عشر من نوفمبر من 70
الى 100% وسجل الطيران اكبر نسبه من اغلاق
الاسواق وذكر مسؤولون الايرانيون في
الاجتماعي ان الطلاب تجمع فتنتين و60
جامعه وكليه واضربوه عن الدراسه في 11
جامعه وقال احد مسؤوله وسائل الاعلام ان
هناك 10 حالته هجوم استهدفت من قاره
الباسيج ومكاتبه ممثل المرشد في عده مدن
بدوره اعترف الجنرال الايرانيه امير علي
زاد قائد القوات الجويه في الحرس الثوري
اعترف بمقتل اكثر من 300 شخص في التظاهرات
والاحتجاجات المستمره في مختلف انحاء
البلاد منذ شهرين لكن هذه الحصيله الرسميه
تقل بكثير عن الحصيله التي اعلنتها منظمه
نشطاء حقوق الانسان في ايران
وتقول هذه المنظمه ان ار 451 محتجا و60 من
قوات الامن قتلوا منذ بدء الاضطرابات كما
اعتقل اكثر من 18,000 شخص
انضموا الينا من لندن الباحث في شان
الايراني حسن راضي سيد حسن مساء الخير
مرحبا بك معي في نشره الرابعه من الرياض
اعتقالات مستمره احتجاجات تزيد رقعتها كل
يوم هل دخلت معها براي قوات البسيج مرحله
الارهاق فعلا كما نقلت ايران انترنال
يعني قضيه ارهاق القوات الامنيه والشرطه
هي ليست بعد مرور اشهر بالاسبوع الثاني
تحدث احد المسؤولين بيننا هناك ارهاق لدى
المسؤول لدى القوات الامنيه حيث قال انه
في الليل والنهار هم موجودين في الشوارع
وايضا همم لا توجد لديهم ايضا دواءفع لهذا
القمع وهو راضين على رواتبهم هذه
الاشكاليات الكبيره مع استمرار الثوره
والدخولها الشهر الثالث بالتاكيد ستزداد
يعني قضيه ارهاق القوات الامنيه
وهناك عجز حتى في القمع يبدو انه قوات
الامنيه لا يوجد لديهم دافع للقمع
ورواتهم قليله وغير راضيين عن الامر حتى
خامني في خطبته الاخيره قال شيئا لابد وان
ناخذها بعين الاعتبار في قضيه همم التعزيز
معنويات القوات الامن هو خلق دوافع لهم
وايضا ارضائهم عما يجري او اعطاهم دوافع
قويه حتى يستمرونا بالقمر وتحدث ايضا حتى
بيسابا عن المتطوعين في الباسيج لكن اريد
السؤال نحن في الشهر الثالث كما ذكرت لهذه
الاحتجاجات هذه المظاهرات التي تاتي على
خلفيه مقتل المساء امينه
الوتيره متزايده متزارعه في كافه المدن
الايرانيه وكذلك كردستان ايران هل يمكن ان
تصل لما هو ابعد من استهداف مقرات البسيج
لما هو ابعد من استهداف مكاتب المرشد
بنفسه
اعتقد بدات الثوره تستهدف كل شيء له علاقه
بالنظام ايراني من اسقاط العمامه الى حرق
التماثيل همم رموز النظام ايراني الى حكم
مقررات البسيج الى حرق حوزات همم يعني
الشيعيه في ايران وكل هذه يعني تعتبر همم
يعني من التنوع الثوره وهذا يعطيها انه
يعني دافع ويعطيها قوه وي- يعني يجعل من
النظام الايراني ان يعجز في امعها لان هم
متنوعه جدا هذا التنوع انه حتى الاحتجاجات
اذا لم يتمكن المواطن للخروج في الشوارع
حتى من داخل الشقق وهو يتف ضد النظام
الايراني
الاضرابات الاعتصامات دخول كل الشرائح في
المجتمع الايراني في هذه الثوره تجعل
تنوعها هو احد التحديات للنظام الايراني
بالتاكيد بهذا التنوع بهذا الزخم ستستمر
على
جهه الاقتصاديه في ايران ترزع في ايه تحت
ظل عقوبات اقتصاديه منذ 2018 عقوبات
امريكيه اثرت على الكثير من الجوانب
الاقتصاديه لديها ارقام مهمه مثلا في
الخامس عشر من نوفمبر همم كما يقول طبعا
تقرير لان ايران انترناشيونال بان معدل
اغلاق الاسواق
من 70 الى 100% وسجلت طيران العاصمه اكبر
نسبه من اغلاق الاسواق فاسال ايضا عن
الاثار الاخرى غير الاجتماعيات الاثار
الاقتصاديه وغيرها كيف يمكن ان تنعكس على
النظام اليوم في مواجهه هذه الاحتجاجات
يعني لو كانت العقوبات الامريكيه كما كانت
في عهد دونالد ترامب الى اثرت بشكل كبير
لكن عندما جاء الرئيس الامريكي الحالي
يعني تراهت العقوبات واصبح لايران اصبحت
ايران بامكانها ان تبيع النفط وايضا يكون
لها تبادل تجاري بكثير خاصه مع الصين ومع
روسيا وقراءه من الدول لكن طبعا القوات
الحرس الثوري الايراني لديها يعني الشركات
باسماء وهميه وتعمل في كل مكان هذا من
جانب اما بالجانب الثاني الموضوع الاقتصاد
والضغوط الاقتصاديه الجراء الاغراءات
بالتاكيد يعني تعتبر تحدي كبير وتضغط على
الاقتصاد الايراني الشبه شبه المنهار يعني
هناك دخلت ايضا يعني شركات مثل التصفيات
النفط اليوم في شيراز ايضا على همم خط
الثوره والعمال والموظفين بعض الاعمال في
كثير من الشركات تحدي يتحدثون عن تسعه
والنظام الايراني لم يدفع لهم رواتبهم هذا
دافع جديد للمحتجين ان يكونون في الشوارع
ويطالبون بسقاط النظامي ايراني لان هذا
النظام لم يحرم المواطنين من الحريات
والقضايا الاجتماعيه
والدكتوره وايضا بسبب ديكتاتوريه السياسيه
حتى لا يعني قطع
عليه يستمرون وايضا
مستوره العمال والتجار والشركات تضغط على
النظام الايراني
مشاركاتك معي في نشره الرابعه من لندن
الباحث في الشان الايراني شكرا جزيلا لك
في مقابله مع العربيه على اهم شيء قمه
المجلس العلمي للسفر والسياحه ذكرى وزير
السياحه السعوديه احمد الخطيب ان القمه
ستشهد وتوقيع 50 اتفاقيه ومذكره تفاهم
بقيمه 50 مليار دولار على هامش القمه بين
المشاركين بما فيهم السعودي
يوجد في القمه اكثر من 400 اعلامي
والمشاركين فيها اكثر من 3000 57 وزير
سياحه وسفر زي ما ذكرنا وقاده القطع سواء
انقطاع الطيران او قطاع الفنادق او قطعه
شركات تنظيم الرحلات والسفر الى اخر ولذلك
تنسيق بينهم العمل فيما بينهم بالغ
الاهميه سيتم عقد اكثر من 50 ورشه عمل
خلال الايام هذه اللي راح يتحدث في هذا
المؤتمر اكثر من 300 متحدث مهمين جدا
بالاضافه الى ان هناك سيتم توقيع اكثر من
50 اتفاقيه ومذكره تفاهم سواء بين المملكه
العربيه السعوديه او بين الشركات المختلفه
سيتم توقيعها في الرياض والتي تتخطى
قيمتها 50 مليار دولار
استطاع قطاع السياحه في السعوديه مشاهدينا
في 2022 العوده الى نحو 70% من مستوياتي
ما قبل الجائحه علما ان مساهمه هذا القطاع
في الناتج المحلي الاجمالي باتت مختلفه
كليا منذ الاعلان عن رؤيه السعوديه 2030
[موسيقى]
من الناتج المحليه الاجمالي للمملكه
مساهمه مختلفه كليا عن ما كانت عليه قبل
اعلان رؤيه 2030
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
عام 2016 وهو عامل اعلان عن الرؤيا بلغ
عدد السياح الاجانب الى السعوديه 18 مليون
و40 الف زياره يقارن ذلك ب 29 مليون و500
الف زياره خارجيه للعام الجاري لحسب اخر
الاحصاءات لنمو يفوق الستينات بهذا تكون
ارقام زيارات الخارجيه للمملكه حتى الان
في 2022 قد تجاوزت نصف الارقام المستهدفه
لرؤيه عند 55 مليون زياره بحلول 20 30 هذا
العام كان القطاع السياحي السعودي الاسرع
عموما بين دول مجموعه ال 20 ففي ذروه
الصيف الماضي في شهر يوليو سجل عدد
السائحين الاجانب الى السعوديه زياده في
221 في المئه مقارنه بمستويات عام 2019
هنا بحسب بيانات منظمه السياحه العالميه
قطاع السياحه واعتبر من اهم القطاعات ضمن
رؤيه المملكه ادمن المستهدف ان يساهم
بعشره في المئه من الناتج المحلي الاجمالي
بحلول عام 2030 باجمالي زيارات يبلغ 100
مليون زياره موزعه بين 55 مليون زياره من
الخارج وخمسه واربعين مليون زياره من
الداخل اما على صعيد سوق العمل فلا تستهدف
الرؤيه ان يستحدث قطاع السياحه مليون
وظيفه تاسيس الهيئه السعوديه للسياحه في
يوم عام 2020 كان له اثر بتفعيل خطط تطوير
القطاع من خلال دورها المتمثل بتطوير
وتنشيط المنتجات السياحيه والتسويق
السياحي واثراء تجربه السائح بسرعه حمدان
العربيه
[موسيقى]
ومن مقر القمه العالميه للسفر والسياحه
بالرياض يلتحق بنا مراسل العربيه نواف
عزيز نواف مساء الخير مرحبا بك معي في
النشره الرابعه من الرياض قبل قليل
استمعنا الى وزير السياحه السعودي احمد
الخطيب يتحدث عن
اتفاقيه تقدر بخمسين مليار دولار عليها مش
هذه القمه ان كانت لديك معلومات حول هذه
الاتفاقيات وما الذي وقع منها هذا اليوم
كذلك
نجحت جهود السعوديه باستضافه القمه
العالميه للسياحه وهي التي تعد الاضخم في
تاريخ القمه وفقا لما كشفته جوليا همم
المدير التنفيذي للمجلس العالمي للسفر
والسياحه يوم امس في المؤتمر الافتتاح
والذي اعلنت في ايضا عن
نيه اعضاء المجلس باستثمار اكثر من 10
مليارات دولار في السعوديه في القطاعات
السياحيه المتنوعه منذ بدايه اليوم ما
ذكره وزير السياحه السعودي يوم امس همم
للعربيه بان اكثر من 50 اتفاقيه يتوقع ان
تبرم حقيقه منذ بدايه هذا اليوم العديد من
الاتفاقيات وزاره الاستثمار وقعت اتفاقيات
ايضا الهيئه السعوديه للسياحه وقعت
اتفاقيه مع الجانب الكوري هذه الاتفاقيه
همم تعزز من عمليات الترفيه والموسيقى في
السعوديه وايضا التسويق التعاوني بين
الجانب السعودي والكوري بينما اتحدث عن
المزيد من الاتفاقيات اترك لكم الصوره
نايف
لمشاهده همم
الزوار في هذه القمه والذي يقتصر دخولهم
على اشخاص مدعوين من مختلف همم دول العالم
مسؤولين ووفود همم على مستويات عاليه من
هذه الدول
وهو ما يتعلق بالقطاع السياحي حول العالم
ايضا هيئه تطوير المنطقه الشرقيه اليوم
اشرفت على توقيع اربع اتفاقيات بقيمه
مليار هذه الاتفاقيات في قطاعات الطيران
وايضا في قطاعات الفنادق مع فنادق عالميه
وقعات همم مثل همم الطيران اوز ايضا الذي
يتواجد بشكل كبير في السعوديه ايضا هناك
تطور متسارع نايف في همم القطاع او
المنظومه السياحيه في السعوديه قبل اسابيع
فقط وزير السياحه اطلق المنصه الموحده
للسياحه والتي توفر معلومات كامله وايضا
تتيح استخراج التراخيص السياحيه
للمستثمرين من الخارج والداخل بشكل فوري
اضافه الى اتاحت خارطه تفاعليه
للجميع تتيح التعرف اكثر على المواقع
السياحيه ومعرفه الخدمات القريبه منها مع
العديد من الخدمات وهذه المنصه منبثقه من
استراتيجيه السياحه الرقميه التي اطلقت
همم في الشهر الثاني من هذا العام في
فبراير الماضي في مؤتمر ليب اضافه الى
العديد من همم
الانجازات التي تمت في هذا القطاع همم
اتفاقيات لا زالت مستمر ايضا هناك نايف
حضور لك من المسؤولين الكبار مثل بانكيمون
الامين العام السابق للامم المتحده وغيره
نعم شكرا جزيلا همم لك على كل هذه
المعلومات من الرياض مراسل العربيه نواف
عزيز
يمثلوا المخطط العام لمطار الملك سلمان
الدولي الجديد في الرياض جزءا مهما من
الاستراتيجيه الوطنيه للنقل والخدمات
اللوجستيه والمبادله الوطنيه لسلاسل
الامداد العالميه الداعمه جهود السعوديه
في تنويع اقتصادها وتحويل الرياض الى احد
اكبر 10 اقتصادات للمدنين عالميه
[موسيقى]
علينا في الاستديو الخبير في قطاع طيران
المهندس طارق العيد مهندس طارق مرحبا بك
من الرياض
انه انت شفت هذا الفيديو اكثر من مره وكل
مره تشوفك انك تشوفها لاول مره
خلينا ينطلق من هنا واسالك انه لماذا يعني
تعتبر هذا الاعلان هو مهم جدا لاي مدى
اصلا هناك حاجه لمطار مثل المطار الملك
سلمان في الرياض وفي السعوديه
كل مره شاهد الفيديو كان يشاهد لاول مره
همم تحدث اسمه سيد الامير محمد بن سلمان
ولي العهد اذا اعلن شيء ياتي بحدث اريد
عنه واعلان يفوق التوقعات وحسب يعني ما
عرفتي القاصر او قدكم مخطئ همم لم يسبق
لتاريخ طيران مدني ان حذر اعلان عن مخطط
بهذه القوه وهذه المتاهله على المستوى
الدولي على المستوى الدولي من تاريخ
الطيران المدني منذ اتفاقيه شيكاغه 1945
اعلان تنسيق قوي جدا على مدى عده مراحل
لمده اكثر من 30 سنه
الرياض
قوي بهالشكل وتصف بهذه الطريقه واحد متابع
مراقب
يعني هذا قطع قطع غيار مهتم ايضا في شيء
الاهميه اللي انت تشوفها فيه قبل الاعلان
هذا يعني اهميه الرياض الرياض اصلا احد
مدرس مظاهر الملك خالد الدولي في الرياض
حاليا المدرسه
تقريبا 25 متر يعتبر ما هبط الطائرات في
مطار الملك خالد الدولي في الرياض احد
المهابط او احد الخيارات لوكاله الطيران
او وكاله الفضاء الامريكيه لهبوط الفضائي
مطار الرياض ما هو الرياض هذا اهميتها
موقع استراتي اللي هو المطار الملك خالد
حاليا همم اذا نظرنا الى مبادرات تعزيز
مكانه الرياض وجعل المملكه مركز لوجستي
همم عالمي للنقل الجوي
نرى ان اهميه وجود نافذه ج همم تربط
الرياض بالعالم اهميه لا يمكن نقاش حولها
نهائيه ولا تقبل القسمه على اثنين لذلك
هذا هذه المبادره باستثمارات ضخمه جدا لم
يعني على ارقامها تهدف لمضاعفه العدد
المسافرين الى سته اضعاف تتكلم عن 185
مليون مسافر 185 مليون مسافر بالارقام
الحاليه
المطار الملك خالد ومطار الملك سلمان
الجديد اكبر من مطار هيثرو في لندن ومطار
دبي ومطار الملك خالد في الوقت الراهن
الان 155 مليون مسافر هذه اهميه موقع
الرياض ان الرياض ممكن تطير انت اللي 70%
المطارات العالم في اقل من خمس ساعات
الاهميه هذه يعني راح تضعف لك زي ما جاء
في البيان ربط بين الشرق والغرب هتكون
مركز محوري همم همم انت انت هتقفز بعدد
المسافرين لست تضعف تقريبا حركه الطائرات
اليوميه حد ضعفها بخمسه اضعاف حركه همم
البضائع والكاربو لا في معلومه ما تغيب
عنك اخو نايف انه 80% من تريد العالمي يمر
عبر المملكه
ومن خلال هذا المطار والمركز يعني هو ليس
مطار فقط بل هو مدينه مطار مدينه مدينه
على على شكل المطار من خلال هذا الموقع
راح تضاعف عدد الوضائع المنقوله الى عشره
الى ثلاثه وثلاثه ونص مليون طن سنويا من
البضائع ثانويه بعشر اضعاف الارقام
الحاليه انت راح ضاعف عدد حركه الطائرات
الى خمسه ضعاف يوميا مقارنه من 211000
حركه في اليوم الى عفوا 211000 حركه سنويه
الى مليون حركه ممتاز يعني ياخذني معك الى
السؤال انه في ناقل جديد سيعلن عنا همم
قريبا حتى يمكن كان في حديث من همم من
فتره يعني قريبه عن هذا الجديد يكون في
الرياض بالاضافه الى الاعلان عن المخطط
طالعه من مطار الملك سلمان الدولي في
الرياض كيف تقرا مستقبل طيران في السعوديه
هذا القطاع باختصار لو سمحت
المستقبل باذن الله مجرد ايام وسنوات
قليله ونوصل باذن الله الرياض ستصبح
الخيار رقم واحد لربط شرق الكره الارضيه
بغربها ستصبح الرياض هي الخيار رقم واحد
باذن الله مع هذه الخطط الطموحه لمن يريد
الانتقال من كوريا او اليابان او استراليا
من شرق الكره الارضيه الى غربيه الى
امريكا
بالتزاوج مع وجود ناقل جوي همم متين كما
اعلن عنه في الايام السابقه اخذ نايف في
تصوري ان الرياضه الارقام يوم امس انه 27
مليار ريال
مدريد
في المملكه العربيه السعوديه وساهم في خلق
اكثر من ثلاث الاف وظيفه مباشره غير
مباشره همم في في الرياض
الشكر على كل هذه المعلومات المهمه في
القطاع ما يخص هذا المطار الجديد انضم
الينا هنا في الاستديو الخبير القطاع
الطيران للمهندس طارق العيد شكله المهندس
الحب حياكم
الرابعه مستمره وتتابعون فيها بعد قليل
عمان تطلقوا نحو 50 مشروعا تنمويا بعشره
ملايين ريال عمانيين العربيه ترصد
التفاصيل
حياكم الله من جديد في عمان يشمله اعلان
وزاره الاقتصاد عن برنامج التنميه الخاص
بمحافظه الداخليه يشمل التنفيذ
47 مشروعا بقيمه تقاربوا 10 ملايين ريال
عماني حيث يشكل اعلان المشاريع الجديده
دفعه نحو تعزيز اللامركزيه واضافه للبنيه
الاساسيه والتي تاتي في اطار المشروعات
ذات البعد الاجتماعي
من مسقط ينضم الينا منفد العربيه عبد
الرحمن العصيمي عبد الرحمن مرحبا بك معي
في نشره الرابعه من الرياض عبد الرحمن ما
الذي رصدته اثناء
تواجدك في عمان حول ما يخص برنامجي
التنميه الخاص بم بمحافظه الداخليه كذلك
الحديث عن المشارع المشاري عفوا الجديده
يعني اللي قبل قليل في الخبر اعلن عن
تنفيذ 47 مشروعا منها بقيمه تقارب
10,000,000 ريال
فعلا نايف اخر زياره صحفيه الى سلطنه عمان
كانت تقريبا قبل اربع سنوات همم سوره
المسقط هذه المره المشهد تغير بشكل كبير
مشاريع عديده همم ايضا في عدد من
المحافظات الموجوده هنا في سلطنه عمان همم
بالتزامن مع العيد الوطني العماني 52 تم
الاعلان ايضا عن مشاريع عشره مشاريع
تنمويه بقيمه 750 مليون ريال همم مليار
عماني تقريبا يعني ما يقارب اكثر من اثنين
مليار همم دولار امريكي 950 مليون ريال
عماني سعد زميلي وليد ياخذ لكم جوله في
هذا المكان هو احد المشاريع الجديده
النوعيه في العاصمه العمانيه مسقط كما
نشاهد هناك يعني شقق سكنيه ايضا ابراج
ومكاتب وايضا مقرات لبعض الشركات العالميه
اذا ما تحدثنا باللغه الارقام نايف
المشاريع العشره الوطنيه اللي تم الاعلان
عنها قبل ايام قليله متوزعه من اكثر من
قطاع الصناعات التحويليه البتروكيماويات
التنقيب عن النفط بالاضافه الى السياحه
والصناعات التحويليه اذا ما تحدثنا عن
مصنع خاص
للكربون سيكون في محافظه شمال الباطن ايضا
هناك محطه تحليه لالمياه في محافظه جنوب
الشرقيه ايضا هناك مصنع للامونيا في
محافظه صلاله بقيمه 178 مليون ريال همم
عماني ايضا هناك حرص على موضوع الامن
الغذائي في سلطنه عمان هناك مزرعه ضخمه
جدا
للدواجن بالشراكه مع احد الشركات
اليابانيه بقيمه 26 مليون ريال عماني في
محافظه الظاهره ايضا مشروع بساط الذي يرفع
الانتاج تقريبا اضعاف ثلاثه من 500 برميل
نفط يوميا الى حوالي 55 همم الف برميل
يوميا في محافظه الوسطى ايضا كما نشاهد
هذا المشروع همم النوعي في اممم العاصمه
العمانيه مسقط هناك حرس كبير ايضا على
تحقيق جوده الحياه في المشاريع العقاريه
الجديده فيما يتعلق بالمقاهي والمطاعم
والخدمات والبنيه التحتيه يوم امس كنا في
مشروع جديد سكني في لواء اليوم نحن في
مسقط ايضا مشروع
عقاري جديد وايضا نشاهد الجميع مستمتع
بالاجواء نايف خاصه الان مع نهايه شهر
نوفمبر الشتاء بدا بالدخول الى سلطنه عمان
فاجواء جميله جدا ومشاريع مستمره وحرص
كبير من همم
على همم
بوادر جيده يارب ان شاء الله
ان شاء الله يرزقنا هنا في عمان لكن
الامطار لسه ما في امطار لكن ربما الايام
المقبله يكون هناك حاله مطريه فا فعلا
المشهد تغير في عمان وهناك حرص كبير من
الشركات العقاريه والشركات الوطنيه على
تقديم مشاريع نوعيه تنمويه تمص المواطن
بالدرجه الاولى وايضا تحقق شفناها
مباشره
في السلطنه مشاريع كبيره وكبيره يعني وهذا
احد المشاريع ايضا همم اللي انت خرجت
اليوم لتتحدث عنها المسقط انا اشكرك كثير
شكرا على كل هذه المعلومات التفاصيل
العربيه مسقط عبد الرحمن حسين
رابع مستمره فيها
الرابعات تناقش اسباب بتعثر المشاريع
الناشئه في السعوديه رغم التسهيلات
الحكوميه المستمره
حياكم الله من جديد يواجه العديد من
المبتدئين في الانشطه التجاريه صعوبات في
بدء مشاريعهم التجاريه بسبب الاشتراطات
والرسوم الحكوميه لمختلف الانشطه كما
تعتبر عدم دراسه المشروعه التجاري بشكل
جيد قبل البدء في اهمه مسببات لتعثر
المشاري او نهائيا
تعثر ملحوظ للعديد من الانشطه التجاريه
الناشئه في السعوديه اسباب مختلفه وراء
هذا التعثر من بينها الحماس وعدم فهم حاجه
السوق وصعوبات التعامل مع الجهات الحكوميه
الاشرفيه فضلا عن الرسوم الماليه التي
تدفع البعض لتعليق انشطتهم او اغلاقها
بشكل نهائي
هنالك رسوم من من وزاره الشؤون بلديه
القرويه هنالك رسوم التامينات الاجتماعيه
من وزاره
القوه البشريه او الموارد البشريه هنالك
رسوم زكاه هناك رسوم
كثيره ترهق همم
المستثمره الصغير هو همم بغض النظر انه هل
هنالك يعني معونات للمؤسسات الصغيره
والمتصل لكن هذه الرسوم مرهقه جدا
وتحبط او تحبط من همه المستثمر تركي مسفر
شاب يوشك على انهاء مشروعه الذي كلفه ربع
مليون ريال بسبب عدم قدرته على مزاوله
نشاطه التجاري على الرغم من مشروعه النوعي
فهو يتخصص في تاجيل الدراجات الهوائيه
المتنقله في الحدائق والمسارات الرياضيه
السعر جميع اللائحه التي طرحتها وزاره
البلديه والشؤون القرويه والاسكان متبعها
بالكامل بند فلما نتبع لا يحاول نتبع جميع
البنود ونطبقها ونفندها في رخصه
همم صادم امات منطقه الرياض ويمنع لي من
العمل فما ما ادري ايش الطريقه او ايش
الحل الذي ممكن مع العلم اني وصلت الى
معالي الوزير تقصر سابقا وصلت اليه مرتين
عده تساؤلات تطرح حول مستقبل الاعمال في
السعوديه
فبالرغم من الدعم الحكومي لتمويل المشاريع
الصغيره الا ان فشل البعض منها اصبح ملفتا
في الاونه الاخيره
من الرياض نواف عزيز العربيه
من مكه المكرمه ينضم الينا الاكاديميه
المهتمه الاعمال الدكتور فواز سعد الدكتور
فواز مساء الخير مرحبا بك معي في نشره
الرابعه من الرياض يعني دعم حكومي تمكين
للمشاريع الصغيره الناشئه يقابله ايضا حتى
رسوم ماليه او غرامات احيانا عاليه كما
يقول طبعا بعض المستثمرين واصحاب الاعمال
بين هذا الدعم تلك الرسوم ما المطلوب من
صاحب المشروع براديك
مساء النور
تقرير جدا ممتاز ولكن القى باللون كثيرا
على
الرسوم
الحكوميه هذا جزء من الاسباب يعني واحد من
اسباب الرئيسي صحيح
يعني حسب الدراسات
يعني عندنا سيبي
انسايدكس فورم همم يقول انه 93% من
المشاريع الناشئه تفشل في عامها الثالث
[موسيقى]
لاسباب كثيره جدا من ضمن
ضعف الخبره عند رائد الاعمال من ضمنها
يعني عدم وجود فريق عمل جيد همم احنا لا
نولد يا دكتور يعني يعني اي صاحب عمل ناشئ
او شركه صغيره هناك حتميه لفشل هذا
المشروع الناشئ او الصغير في عام الثالث
او الثاني نعم اذا لم يكن هناك رصيد
تراكمي من الخبرات المتنوعه لدى هذا الشخص
سواء كان بدراسه او بعده مشاريع جربها
واشتغل عليها هو اعمال ثقلت تجربته خبته
همم بلا شك هذا مو بس عندنا في كل العالم
ممكن تكون مثلا قله الخبره هي السبب ال
همم الوحيد لفشل هذا المشروع او انها او
اغلاق او تعليقه او حتى يعني خلينا نقول
تاجيله لا طبعا ليست فقط ضعف الخبره نبدا
بسبب الرئيسي الكبير هو في خلل في اللي
احنا بنسميه البزنس اسمه كم بس او نموذج
العمل التجاري هذا نموذج العمل يشتمل على
ايش اول شيء القيمه المضافه من المشروع قد
لا تكون واضحه لدى رائد الاعمال ومؤسسا
مشروع قد لا يكون منتجك او خدمتك لها حاجه
في السوق
ضعفت تخطيط والتوقعات الماليه هيكل
الايرادات هيكل التكاليف التسعير نفاض
الكاش ال- ال- همم فريق العمل توقيت نزول
الخدمه والمشروع همم حماس ضعف الحماس همم
الدكتور في في موضوع ايضا مهم اخر دائما
اي شخص صاحب مشروع ان شاء الله ويبدا في
هذا العمل همم بيكون امام همم يعني شيء
مفترض انه يعمل اللي هو دراسه الجدول لهذا
المشروع برايك احيانا هل هذا خلال رئيسي
ربما انه دراستهجد وهذه لم تكن دقيقه لم
تكون صحيحه وبالتالي تنعكس اكثر على صاحب
العمل تجبره على الاغلاق او على برفع يده
من هذا العمل يعني بالضبط هذا هذا كثير
جدا سواء في المشاريع عن الناشئه
التقليديه زي المطاعم والكافيهات وغيرها
او في المشاريع المبنيه على
الابتكانيه التطبيقات وما هي الا ذلك
دائما
معرفه ارقام المشروع وكم يدخن وكم التسعير
وكما الربح وكم الخساره ووضوح هاني دراسه
الجدوى امر مهم جدا هو سبب رئيسي طيب
دكتور اذا مشروع او فشل كما قلت اشرح يصير
على الدعم الحكومي لهذا المشروع سواء من
بنك التنميه او من المنشات او غيره يعني
طبعا بلا شك احنا نقول انه فيه انت الان
المنافسه زادت والاميله يعني يبغى خدمه
مميزه وممتازه
ورؤيتنا في 20 30 البلد قاعده تعزز باتجاه
الاحترافيه في الاعمال
الناس الصغار اللي ما يقدروا يقدموا خدمات
راقيه قد لا يكون لهم وجود في المستقبل
وبالتالي لذلك الناس تشتكي من كثره الرسوم
لكن في نفس الوقت عندك اكثر من 10 15
برنامج الحكومي يسهل لرائد الاعمال ان يشق
الطريق يعني بنك التنميه الاجتماعيه هذا
واحد ولديه اكثر من 10 برامج تبدا من
تمويل من 300,000 الى 8,000,000 عندك بعد
كده همم هي العمل للمشاهده الصغيره
المتوسطه
ربما ايضا حتى اذا صار اكبر في في الشركات
مثل الاستثمار الجريء وغيره خليني اسالك
اخيرا عن عن عن واقع ال ال السوق السعودي
اليوم في ما يخص هذه
خلينا نسميها المشاريع الصغيره او الناشئه
برايك انت دكتور فواز سعد هل وصل السوق
السعودي الى الاكتفاء من هذه المشاريع من
هذه المنشات ايضا الصغيره وبالتالي نسبه
نجاح اي مشروع يعني ستكون ضئيله مقارنه
بمكان عليه الوضع قبل سنتين الى ثلاثه
لا ابدا انا لا اعتقد ذلك لانه اي اقتصاد
مزدهر ومتنوع يبنى على المشاريع الصغيره
والناشئه لذلك السوق موجود طالما رايد
الاعمال عرف هو بالضبط ايش يقدم كيف يتميز
على المنافسين ويقدم خدمه جديده ويخلق
حاجه او يضيف قيمه مميزه مختلفه عن
المنافسين في السوق وهو يستطيع الوصول
بمشروعه ومنتجه الى بره الامان والنجاح
ذلك
من المشاريع الصغيره
من مكه المكرمه الينا الاكاديميه المهتم
باليده الاعمال الدكتور سعد شكرا دكتور
السعوديه اعلنت الهيئه العامه للترفيه عن
وصول عدد زواري موسم الرياضه 2022 الى
اكثر من خمسه ملايين زائر وذلك منذ
انطلاقه في اواخر اكتوبر الماضي
ومجموعه من الفعاليات الرياضيه مثل دبليو
دبليو اي
65 يوما من فعاليات الالعاب الناريه كما
يحتوي على مجموعه كبيره من المسرحيات
السعوديه والعربيه وعدد من الحفلات
الغنائيه والمعارض المحليه كذا العالميه
تنقسم الاوديه الى عده انواع منها الخطير
والاخطر ذلك لقوه جريان مياهها التي تجرف
كل ما يقف في طريقه التفاصيل في تقويم مع
خالد
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
خلوا كل واد
راه قاعده من قواعد اهالينا رحمهم الله في
فن التعامل مع الطبيعه
وقوانينها مفادها ان نتجنب الجلوس والنزول
والبناء في بطون الاوديه ومجاري الشعاب
صيفا وشتاء ففي الصيف مراتي على الهوام
وفي الشتاء مجاريا للاوديه لانها تمثل
خطوره بالغه على قاطنيها فاكبر وادي
بالعالم يسمى بوادي الرمه سمي بهذا لانه
هرم اياك الكل اللي جالس بطريقه فلها حرمه
ويجب ان نحترم حرمتها بعدما التخطيط
والبناء والنزول واحترز لفظا وكان بصحبه
الحمقى وارباب الخلل انا مثل الماء سهل
ومتى احمي هذا
وقتل
[تصفيق]
والاودي انواع ومن اخطرها التي تعيش بين
ثنايا الجبال والمرتفعات كجبال تهامه
وعسير ومرتفعات اليمن وسلطنه عمان فلها
قوه جارفه ومن قوتها انها تجرف الصخور ولا
يحد قوته الا البحر والقيلوله لا تكون الا
بعز الغيظ والجيط ما به مطر والعامه
يقولون لا تنام بالمسيل
لو المجيد
[موسيقى]
المباراه المرتقبه بين ايران والولايات
المتحده ضمن كاس العالم لكره القدم عدت
الى الاذهان ذكريات مونديال 1998 بمشاهد
الاحترام المتبادل بين لاعبي البلدين
المتعادين سياسيا مواعيد او مواعيد مختلفه
حضرت فيها سياساته بقوه في ملاعب الرياضه
نشاهد
[موسيقى]
قبل الختام هذا التذكره العلوم
الصراع الدور الاول في المونديال يبدا
جوله الحسم موقعه امريكيه ايرانيه بنكهه
السياسه
شكرا لكم لكلمه لطفي المتابعه عوده القاكم
يوم غدا في رعايه الله
[موسيقى]